the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it in the night past
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media look
um I want to thank you guys for
supporting this show every week it gets
tougher and tougher to do this show
because of YouTube they pull it out of
the algorithm because we talk about real
stuff we talk about words if I say right
now we'll get this episode demonetized
um so thank you for supporting this show
it's an important show I love what we do
over here we're not just hanging we're
talking about real stuff and you're
getting to know what you know the True
Stories Behind these people
um thank you for supporting the YouTube
special uh they also pulled that off
Lefty son they demonetized that so if
you want to support the special you got
to go find it and watch it it was
crushing it had over half a million
views in two weeks and then Boop they
pulled it we appealed it they said nah
so it is what it is uh but if you're
looking for more and you gotta have more
and you gotta check out the patreon it's
the Honeydew with y'all and I'm telling
you every week it gets Wilder and Wilder
and I say that every week here and then
I don't know what we're going to listen
to and then I hear stuff and I'm like
what are you talking about so it's five
bucks a month and if you're out there
and you got a story that has to be heard
please submit it to honeydew podcast
gmail.com hopefully we'll get to do an
episode together and if you're looking
for a new podcast to listen to I'm
telling you go listen to my old podcast
the crab Feast it's still doing crazy
numbers you guys are loyal you guys are
awesome and today's guest actually had a
great episode on there so uh that's the
the biz right there now look I'm on tour
we're adding a bunch of dates we got a
bunch more this year we're gonna be out
all year next year I gotta go a little
slow because everything that happened to
me as you know but June 23rd and 24th
I'll be in Tacoma Washington July 7th
and 8th I'm in Appleton Wisconsin go get
your tickets at ryancicle.com you'll see
a bunch of dates added if I'm in your
town when when you're there come out and
see me there it is
you know what we're doing over here
we're highlighting the low lights I
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers today I am very excited
to have my guest here for the first time
on the Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome Frankie Quinones
did I say it right yeah yeah right you
hit the end yeah
well dude it's good to have you here
um we've been talking about this for a
minute so before we get into anything
plug promote everything all of it please
oh oh [__] okay well my name is Frankie
Quinones at Frankie Quinones on all
social media platforms uh I'm on a show
called this fool on Hulu which I make
with one of my best friends and or uh
I'm a co-star with him and then uh we
got Michael imperioli's another main
character it's a good vibe best way I
could describe it it's like the movie
Friday meets the show Atlanta
um but we got the second season
premiering July 28th that's a big deal
it's hard to get a second season yeah
especially nowadays you know how it is
out here homie and also be on the uh uh
upcoming season of uh what we do in the
shadows and then um yeah other than that
homie just you know trying to keep it
moving hitting the clubs doing the stand
up and trying to navigate through these
algorithms that are [__] us up
I'm screwed on mine all that time effort
money for YouTube to go nah nah crazy
which is why the patreon's important
subscribe to the patreon they don't edit
you over there
um cholo Fitness first of all if you
haven't seen that dude yeah it's one of
the funniest damn things is that what
what started the show for you is that
like what's got the ball rolling with
Hulu no not with Hulu just in general in
my career so this fall be 17 years since
I started chasing this dream and uh
naturally in my stand-up I'll you know
I'd be storytelling and imitating my
family and voices and stuff like that I
was already doing multiple characters
but I did a character based on my Father
which is old school homie Osco cholo but
one of the most positive people I know
always Chuck Taylor's Dickies creased up
always drive to Lolo but always driving
me little league practice you know what
I'm saying being a good dad and so um
that's what creeper is the character's
name is that and you know he started
total fit to tap into that positive
partner hey homie I'm trying to get you
in shape and get your knife right yeah
and um and uh that that went viral
and it was a little overwhelming because
I was you know I was doing it you know
I'm from out here so it's like I thought
it was just gonna be that but man I
remember it was like that like we posted
it we're like damn I was doing pretty
good I woke up in the morning I had
messages from
Thailand from [__] Canada from the
the dopest one was uh dude I got these
dudes from Australia they sent me a a
photo right and it's two of them doing a
trouble Squad and they had a baby joey
you know a kangaroo in the middle
looking like he's doing it and they're
like
cholo fit mate and I was like what the
[__] is happening on me like fools that
didn't even order cholo was they still
embraced the character for whatever
reason so that's when I was able to
start getting weekends at clubs and
really start hitting the road before
that my first big break was my my boy
Craig Robinson took me on the road and
uh he's the one who you know got me
acclimated to that road life and helped
me know the clubs and and um you know he
really uh was a great mentor and he just
he was the first one to open the door
for me you know so
uh but I was still struggling sleeping
on the homies couch for 200 bucks a
month but when cholofit went viral I was
able to start hitting the road and then
um and then me and my homies made a show
called dress-up gang which is a sketch
group that I'm a part of dress-up gang
uh you could look that up just look up
dress-up gang on YouTube We got some
funny [__] cute house Frankie in the
water we got all these sketches we made
a show for TBS speaking of algorithm
things
uh in 2017. so 2017 is when my life uh I
was serving uh delivering a sandwich
when I got the call that we sold that
show and
um I was delivering it to like this
white college kid at the dorms in UCLA
and they got a call and they go yo
[__] we sold the show they want
10 episodes and I almost just ate the
sandwich but then
the funny thing is
called shizo what's up dude you know
[__] thanks for my sandwich and I'm
like yeah and I was like dude [__]
your your mind I was just so emotional
at the time
you're my last delivery homie I almost
didn't deliver it but me and my homies
just sold the show to [__] TBS and he
was like yeah cool man like uh you know
did you bring any mayonnaise like you
know he's just like he didn't go he
thought I was [__] out of my mind
like okay sure bro isn't it funny like
when you dream about your dream you
dream all these things yeah you know
what I mean and then you get a call
about a 10 episode pickup when you're
delivering a [__] sandwich you
know what I'm talking about you don't
you don't see that in the you know what
I mean
it's not like that like it's also funny
to me that we pour
like everyone we pour all our lives into
this one thing and then this this little
ant that works next door this little
worker aunt's like good for that I don't
even know who the [__] that guy is give
him a [__] sandwich yeah you know
what I mean and it's nothing to them and
everything to us it's crazy and whatever
he's going after like that's cool you're
uh yeah you're the answer of doctors oh
that's cool yeah yeah whatever that's
what's up where's my [__] Sandwich
Man check my blood pressure [__]
oh [__] um all right well let's talk
about your life because you definitely
had a different upbringing
um you grew up out here but you talk
about your mom you talk about your dad
let's let's talk about your girl yeah
man it's like uh I've had a good life on
me you know what I mean but uh
I was the one where like kind of like my
mom and dad they they got us out of the
hood you know that whole [__] I know
everybody has that story but not
everybody I mean well you know you hear
that's uh yeah sorry I'm on like I need
to be more confident I'm a super
insecure [__] you know what I
mean like oh hey sorry for existing but
anyways my mama
she's uh she's the one that she's the
funny one the outgoing one she grew up
she grew up uh the oldest of all her
siblings and the projects I mean the
colonial projects six and so she helped
raise those kids because she had a
military father who was abusive and I
used to be uncomfortable talking about
that because that's my grandpa you know
right and there might be some of my
family that watches this man I might be
uncomfortable saying this but he [__]
up homie you know he abused his own
children he abused his daughter which is
my mom and in every way
you know anyways my point is my dad
lived around the block on me in the same
hood you know what I'm saying same thing
sharing a room with all his siblings but
they were the ones that [__] somehow
the universe brought that they met when
they were in the playground you know in
the neighborhood playing legit my dad
was like eight my mom was like five or
six when they met you know what I'm
saying and then um
my uh my dad borrowed a sister's car and
he was 16. my mom was about 14 and they
went on their first date you know what
I'm saying but my point is is that they
had a lot of things against them you
know and like being abused like that
especially for my mother like people
literally telling her like you ain't
never gonna be [__] look where we're at
what the [__] and they overcame that man
and they did it and then I saw him when
I was young when they didn't have money
how powerful like humor was to them they
were Die Hard stand-up fans on me you
know what I'm saying who they like like
Paul dog so when they were dating they
would drink their alcohol in the parking
lot and Order soda for their two drink
minimums they would go to a comedy store
the Hollywood improv no [__] I'll go see
Live Comedy yeah so when they come see
me there it's like you know what I'm
saying wow but they would they would let
me watch it when I was a Youngster here
is in the bad parts but you know I'm
like this yeah and uh we're watching
Richard Pryor Eddie Murphy one of their
favorites was George Carlin which was
dope to me because I'm seeing this young
Mexican couple as a kid you know because
George Carlin was awesome intelligent
[__] he's breaking down what the what
the [__] oh really is going on politics
all that [__] homie and they were being
they don't know nothing about that but
it's because the humor they were into
the humor it brought him into that he
that [__] educated them and was
like yeah he's right and he's making me
laugh at the same time I'm like it was
just levels of [__] and then you know
Paul Rodriguez was the first one I saw
look like me on TV and then um and then
you know we as as we got older they were
they were uh they started doing better
at life they're they're hard workers man
they were just working every day of the
week you know just me and my sister
doing the damn thing just to you two
kids
um at first it was just yeah yeah they
just had two of the kids and we used to
live in a one bedroom apartment in San
Fernando in the valley and then um and
then and then they saved up man and they
got us out of there we moved to a
cul-de-sac and [__] and I was like damn
you know like to go from a woman Perma
to a cul-de-sac like [__] crazy you know
if it was a rollerblading [__] and I'm
like I'm actually working out a bit
right now or like my mom's jealous of me
that I'm going rollerblading with like
these like these white dudes down the
block you know like yeah
[Applause]
oh you're having fun rollerblading huh
like [__] okay enjoy it you know like
but uh you know our neighborhood still
diver we weren't bawling we just got you
know we got a two-story home and a
cul-de-sacs it's funny cul-de-sac is a
word I don't know I I grew up learning
court right
and then later in high school I was like
somebody said cul-de-sac and I'm like
what the [__] is that yeah it's a little
dead I'm like you mean a court or like
same [__] yeah yeah same [__] are we
yeah you're moving up if you gotta if
you live in a band yeah and it was kind
of funny too because we were on a court
we got a corner house and my mom they
signed the worst loan deal ever like my
my Mom Dad just wanted to get us out man
they want to get us out they want they
were so dedicated to their kids you know
what I'm saying I'm forever indebted to
them for that you know what I mean but
they were in over their heads man we
were constantly getting our power turned
off constantly getting our water turned
off but my dad had the tool to turn the
water back on so he would be like hey is
everybody take it ready to take a shower
you go out there all right take a shot
check out all right turn around you know
you know
and then I'll never forget this man
my uh one time we got the power turned
on when you're a kid you're not tripping
off like you know I mean if you have
cereal until you're like hey it's
whatever but I'll never forget this like
we had the power turnover time but my
mom had a boom box though and uh uh and
uh she had double D back you know the
Double D batteries Boombox now she lit
the candles we had a power turn she lit
all the candles [__] put the Beats on
and she's dancing with me and my sister
you know just anything and so as kids
you're like oh [__] we're having a
little Candlelight party and to think
the pain that is happening and my
parents were they can't even keep the
power on but they're just dancing it off
making me feel good about that whole
[__] that's why my whole thing is like
very unsung yeah yeah it's just like
positivity humor and music is one of
them you know that's one of the most
powerful things is their religion homie
especially like old school Funk my
sister's name is Tina Marie after Tina
Marie they went to Rick James's funeral
like that that was their [__] homie you
know what I mean like that that my mom
calls him her Ricky Rick my Ricky Rick
you know
but um anyways my point is man is that
was my biggest inspiration is
seeing how powerful and strong humor
laughter somebody be listening to your
podcast having the worst day but you say
some [__] that makes them laugh like you
know what man I'll be all right because
you know we're good it's also
perspective you know it's like you hear
someone else's story sometimes and I for
me sitting in this seat over the years
I'm like man what the [__] am I bitching
about you know what I mean like for real
when you hear somebody else you're like
good god dude you went through all that
yeah no but still though we did it homie
like you know come on man you got your
own [__] up with you look at here
look at this guy right here you know
he's like you're dressed in Nebraska
University hell yeah you know what I'm
saying tell me about
um growing up you said you you struggle
with uh addiction
like when I drink before I drink for
like two days I don't get there I want a
burrito and a sack of Pancakes to go on
SportsCenter go to sleep
but when you start getting the drugs
involved you know because I'm trying to
uh Escape for me it's the only thing
that works and drugs do work until they
stop working you know you feel me and so
even though I had a loving Mom and Dad
we still
grew up how we grew up and it's like my
mom
you know it's your intergenerational
trauma my mom was abusing every way you
know my dad you know he had a you know
he grew up in a rough neighborhood he's
out there in the streets
so uh you know they don't have those
tools they were never went to therapy
none of that so they were professional
suppressors you feel me and so well said
you know my my uh I had some Primos that
you know they used to stay with us and
stuff like that because my dad was
looking out for them
and uh cousin sorry but I know what I
know
but uh but yeah yeah I would say the
most I've had a good life on me because
I had love you know some [__]
never get loved their whole life and
sometimes you give the you can give the
worst person a small amount of love and
it changes their whole life you know
what I'm saying and um and and that and
so but for me I had love in the home
it's just that we didn't have the tools
to deal with all this [__] so
one of my older cousins so I was you
know I'm trying to be down you know you
know you're being I was like five six
seven years old for three years this was
happening but you know you look up to
your older cousin you look out you look
up yeah they're like brothers and
sisters you know another somebody else
exactly you're looking after to protect
you and they're gonna teach you about
life and and then you know he ends up
[__] molesting me you know for
[__] three years you know and it's
like and by the third year I was like
and how old are you I was five six and
seven years old and he's a teenager
middle school he's uh he's about 17. 16
17 yeah in high school yeah so like if
you mind me asking you what he's doing
to you like how does that even start
oh man it's uh
you know hey let's you know we're
playing with my toys on the floor and
the thing you know you know you just
start
you know I started [__] around he's
touching touching [__] you know just
take a shower you know and
because I'm over there thinking he's
like babysitting me you know it's all
love it's familiar so they're gone we're
good or they're they're in the house you
know but they're just doing other [__]
you know I'm I'm a kid on me so right
you know nothing you know I still feel
guilt like I did that [__] I'm a gross
[__] dude you know
uh but
you still feel gross about it you know
I'm trying to process the [__] you gotta
understand because it's five years old
you don't even you don't you still
believe in Santa Claus exactly homie you
know what I'm saying you still believe
in fairies and [__]
and so
I just thought that that's what life was
and okay this is how we're connecting
you know but it's like
you know he's we're [__] doing the
whole [__] man like he's like look he
goes he's [__] going down on my [__]
that's how you doing I'm going down
there looking up at him like you know
[__] about like am I doing good
it's like that's a tough thing man and
for the longest time [__] I held
that [__] in for 27 years cause what the
[__] when did you find it what are
people gonna say about me when they hear
this [__] I don't give a [__] anymore
man you shouldn't I think more of us
should talk about it yeah a lot of
[__] so men so many men don't
do you so they do what you said they
professional suppressors let me just
push that [__] down [__] it and then it
it manifests in other ways whether it's
addiction or abuse or all of it you know
I we have got to talk about mental
health men we're in this weird position
as men we our generation specifically
because I go back to thinking about like
my grandfather's time those men fought
in World War II
then there's my father's era those men
were going to Vietnam then there's us
like I want to be a clown and they're
like what the [__] are you talking about
yeah what kind of man I want to act I'm
like what yeah you want to ask okay bro
yeah like what the [__] I need to get
your ass to work but also at the same
time do you have kids no kids so we're
also the the Our Generation of of these
dads that are the I love you dads the
dads that are going to therapy trying to
break all that generational [__]
yeah yeah so that we don't pass that on
to the next and the next and the next
and keep it going so that's a weird
[__] time to be a man in this world
uh where you know what men used to be
and where they're going and all the
[__] that's right there in the
middle so I'm glad to hear you talk
about it I know that shit's not easy to
talk about I don't know I don't want you
to sit and live in that those memories
but tell me you said you suppressed it
for 20 what years 27 years man and when
did it pop for you where you're like no
more of no more of me just dealing with
this when did it shift for you where you
were like I gotta talk about this and
get better about this oh man
uh
because honestly for the longest time I
was like ah you know it's not a big deal
I've had a good you know I got homies I
got my family I got childhood my
childhood's cool I got Kool-Aid and
tortillas hey we're good
you know and then uh you know you kind
of
have ways of deflecting it you get good
at it
and you know it's one of the things Me
and Bobby Lee had because Bobby Lee you
know he's sober and all that [__] and we
kind of went through some similar [__]
and he was like you know that's why we
got good so good at being funny is
because
you want everybody to like you and you
don't want to feel like that person that
you felt when you were doing that [__]
up [__] you know but I was like always
just trying to fit in homie and just
trying to figure this [__] out and it's
like to have nobody you know you're
seven years old I finally
got him or you know I put him up you
know I kind of announced it and so it
got shut down but for three years I
should deal with it and then it was like
all right don't ever talk about it again
you know for so no first for nobody to
come and check on you like as a seven
year old like not even remember
so oh yeah at seven yeah so after a
couple years of it yeah
like and then drove him home and then
never talked about it again
and still would invite him to you know I
still got to see my family parties all
this it was like that that's how we do
in our community homie like hey all
right that happened but okay it stopped
on so just forget about it you know but
and honestly hold me in my whole life I
thought I'm good I've had I got a good
light [__] my [__] [__] we out here
we're living the Earth the trees but as
you get older it wasn't until I was
getting in my 30s it started eating me
you know because I never dealt with it
you know I never process it I had this
scary little [__] kid sucking you
know [__] doing that getting molested
inside of me and he was like yo
[__] if you don't take care of
me shit's gonna get [__] up in here
you know and so I [__] turned to
drugs dog I'm sorry [__] whatever you
know can we go back for a second did
your mom tell your dad or was this a
secret from your dad did you tell your
dad no I told both I told both of them I
sat down you know and I was like Hey
Mama like uh I don't know like I thought
it was uh cool like I thought it was
like whatever but now I feel weird like
but here's what's been happening you
know and then when I at 27 years later I
mentioned that to him they they were
like we don't remember that
it they were they like they blocked
suppresses so hard and blocked it out
that they literally took it from their
memory you know neither one of them
remember it no until later when I was
like [__] you know I I you know
because of sag you know Union you get
Assurance I was like [__] maybe
insurance covers a therapy so maybe I
should go you know
and um and then you know they educate
you on all that [__] and they gave me
the literature and they're like look
[__] you got PTSD you got
[__] this you got [__] now this is
what happened to you yeah and
and it was amazing because it was like
it was just incredible to find that
information and it's also comforting
because I'm like oh damn they print
literature on the [__] that I've been
through that means all these
[__] are going through this
[__] but it's like
it was just incredible to to
see that like damn I've been living my
whole life like that like
every decision I made in life that
shit's been affected you know every time
I walk into a room of strangers and I
feel that sense of insecurity it's all
come you know from this place but with
that being said like [__] homie I got a
roof over my head foot on the table I'm
mate I made it in this comedy [__] I'm
not like an ego [__] I don't
think I'm like hey I'm the funniest
[__] but to go from from that I
was already 35 sleeping on my homies
couch but the [__] popped for me you
know thank thankfully and so there's
always a fear of failure and there's
also a fear of success and people think
[__] money's gonna bring happiness
and all that dog I [__] bought my I
never thought I'd be a homeowner you
know it's only a little condo but I
bought that [__] out here you
know yeah right where I'm from and and
yet I would still bring myself to a
place where I'm on my knees in the
living room of my own pad that I bought
just begging the [__] Universe to
take this monster from me so I don't
keep trying to destroy myself you feel
me yeah but at the same time from that
Darkness homie I get on that stage and
I'm like I could be a room full of
strangers and I'm like I got y'all we
about to feel good yeah cause it's all
you know that's what I love about
Comedians and starting this show too
made me fall in love with Comics all
over again because they're we're some of
the people that can take the ugliest
[__] and spin it into something that's
so funny and makes other people feel so
[__] good like that's magic man
that's a magic thing that we've
possessed instead of just going angry
with it and shooting up a [__]
building or some [__] like that you know
what a difference
they didn't have comedy they'd be that
little blowing up a building no doubt
yeah so do you ever see this cousin
anymore is this dude still alive yeah
yeah he's around man yeah and have you
ever talked to him
we need to go to lunch we need something
we talk about this because you know I
started I did start going over you when
you did when you made him go to lunch we
haven't gone yet oh [__] it's only been
like a year ago that I told him sorry so
he's still like you know around me and
[__] man the only thing is I went
through stages with it I'd be like
I'm like piss at that [__] yeah
this is like family too like what the
[__] on me you did that [__] to me like
as I got older you know I'm like [__]
that fool but then I would think damn
the [__] that he went through
right who was doing that to him exactly
right so this so I started sympathizing
because I just didn't want to be angry
anymore homie but now I'm at a point
like all right you know I see him and
we're cordial because my grandpa's my uh
my abuelito's 95. we always have
barbecues and I don't want to like kill
the vibe for my grandpa he's like but
he's about to literally yeah I know
right yeah literally so you know I'll
say what's up and everything and the
thing is is you know his brother's one
of my best friends and all that and they
no no nobody knows you know so no one
knows because your mom and Dad shut it
down
repressed it forgot about it I mean and
he'd obviously never so whose son is
this by the way this is your mom's
sister brother your dad's yeah too many
details but
you know I pretty much some people are
gonna be watching this podcast you know
but yeah it's on my dad's side but
anyways what if they're watching this
podcast and they're like holy [__] that
happened to me too what if you're not
the only one yeah and that's very
possible you know of course it's
possible but my main thing right now is
like I I you know I know not to he's
never apologized to me for it that's the
thing you know but
like my pop my pops and my mom after I
told him after that 27 years
I said man what the [__] man like you
know that [__] [__] me up
it happened in our own path
if you don't feel safe in your own home
homie where the [__] are you gonna feel
safe in the world you know I'm out here
scared dog
I'm scared of this [__] you know
that's why I'm like [__] it let me just
make entertain as many people as I can
because I don't know what the [__]
gonna happen
but you know I would love to get an
apology from him and I feel like that
was solving or just here like I just
hope that you're still not doing it you
know yeah that's a great point I mean
think of that are you continuing that
behavior
and and the thing is like he would be
doing that [__] but he would protect me
you know like which was weird that's
confusing yeah what do you mean like
when we be on the streets and [__] like
like him you know and his brothers and
all my other cousins they're they're all
they were all gang bangers I even went
through a safe shop like oh I want to be
down with him and I got the Dickies and
the thing and that's why I got this dent
in my I don't know if you can see it but
I got like a little yeah I see it from
one man to be honest I I found out
sprung on a chola homie I was like [__]
I want to get with her and then you know
she saw my cousins were so I you know I
[__] was like oh you know what I'm
gonna [__] get all cholo Style with
it my mom was like you ain't wearing
that [__] my dad's like not let him
cause my dad knew he's like I'm gonna
let the [__] learn but he would
wake me up at 5am to make sure I crease
my [__] did he really because he was
like yeah you're gonna rock this [__]
you're gonna do it right five a.m
[__] homie at 12 years old
he's waking me up at 5 a.m
to go to [__] Junior High anyways
[__] I'm in the bathroom at school
and these [__] fools from another
Hood come to me for your process showing
up my [__] and they jump me you know and
they slam my head against the metal door
did they and I got 12 Staples in my head
and and my you know my mom told me not
to work so I go home land or I'm like no
we're playing basketball and I have L on
a brick wall and ah dang you know and so
I made up these lights but but that's
but I'm glad that happened at a young
age at 12 because I immediately switched
back to Bugle Boy jeans and cargo shorts
you know
I was trying to be something I wasn't
homie I'm in a fighter homie I'm a lover
dog you know what I'm saying like so
yeah
so you know uh but but my Primos always
had my back and even the most gangster
ones even though without trying to be
down with them they always knew homie
they told me they're like you're gonna
do something special Primo you know even
though for most [__] up ones you know
and I have one cousin he was all drunk
one night and I'm kicking in he had a
strap you know and he's just drunk and
he's like damn you know he's holding it
to my face how does that feel how does
that feel
just tell me pretty much I feel how does
that feel right there like [__] with
me I had nightmares about that [__] for
like 10 years I bet but like about four
years ago he apologized to me for it and
why and why do you apologize did he just
come to it on his own or did you say
something about it no he remembered on
his I must been [__] with him too
exactly which made me feel even more
because he's got a good heart man right
he was off that [__] he was smoking
[__] meth and [__] he was just gone
homie but I didn't even think he
remembered but [__] man when he told me
that [__] I cried I hugged him and I
said [__] love you homie out of
nowhere he came up to and said it yeah
and he goes hey man remember that [__]
when I'll be [__] with you when you
were a little kid because it wasn't just
that like he had me in the corner of a
garage with a weed whacker to my face
like [__] yeah he would be doing [__]
like that to me too you know
and uh you know but it did kind of
toughen me up in a way even though I'm
not a fighter I know that if you want to
[__] around on the street though you
will get [__] up you know like and
especially nowadays it's crazy like it
would be 16 year old popping off to you
I'm like this little [__] and
then all of a sudden it's like Batman
you're dead it's like I'm trying to keep
it cool homie and so that's what uh I
asked Sally Sadiq what he missed about
prison and he said the one thing that he
truly missed about prison was in prison
there's consequences for running your
[__] mouth oh yeah most people aren't
on uh well nobody's on a keyboard making
their little [__] comments if you're
gonna say something to somebody you
better be you better be [__] ready
because it's all aggressive Alpha
[__] in there that want some of
that smoke oh yeah yeah give me all of
it you want something let them go
they're like they're bored okay what's
up you ain't gonna walk up just so you
know be a Karen all popping off about
[__] because in there you're gonna get
[__] yeah
so if somebody's got a problem with you
in prison then you know they got a
problem with you oh yeah you know it's
gonna be something man out here on the
streets where everybody thinks they can
run their [__] mouth and then pull a
gun out and uh not in prison I mean they
might have a shank or something they
made but they had to put time and effort
into that [__] you know what I mean it's
not the quick pow and you're [__] not
a place for me if you need an afternoon
reset do yourself a favor and snag five
minutes for a dad grass tote break or
two they've got Mom grass joints it's
the perfect pick-me-up to spark or
creative flow or the original dag grass
joins to quiet your mind after your nine
to five that grass is legal organic
smokable hemp that relaxes your body and
Mellows your mind they're 100 organic
pre-rolled joints and flour are very low
in THC and high in CBD so you can enjoy
the effects of CBD while keeping a clear
head if you're not looking to toke that
grass also offers the finest tincture
and gummies on the market all the Mellow
goodness no smoke required all dagrass
products are federally legal for ages 18
and over and it ships right to your door
anywhere in the U.S whether you're
looking for a new Buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite dad grass will
leave you in a euphoric mood right now
that grass is offering my listeners 20
off your first order when you go to
daggrass.com honeydew go to dadgrass.com
honeydew for 20 off your first order
that's dadgrass.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do so
he apologized man that meant a lot to
you huh hell yeah homie hell yeah he's
because he's a good harder person now
you know you got to [__] together
all right so tell me about this cousin
only a year ago so what's what's the
delay for him he knows he doesn't want
to yeah honestly I need to take the set
be like hey yo I'm about to swoop you up
yeah I'm gonna go to lunch you know but
the thing is I can't be just from the
therapy you know they told me you don't
go in expecting an apology or whatever
but check this out homie I'll run around
Ramble On too much but
um we got a little time when you know
and I told my mom and dad about it and
they were like my dad was like well [__]
that he's not invited in this pad
anymore this is 27 years after you know
and [__] like and some of my other
family became aware of it and then like
a month later
[__] they invited him to a barbecue
uh that they knew I was gonna be at only
one month after I said like yo this [__]
went down
and I show up homie and I swear my heart
dropped I felt just like I didn't even
know what to feel I went inside on the
couch in the living room not he's just
out there Manning the grill you know and
I'm like do they not believe me
did I am I being a [__] did I [__] up
and so I wrote a joke about it it's my
favorite joke homie and I can't tell it
and every time I'm still not there yet
to be confident or tell it but in some
alt rooms and [__] like that I'll say it
you know I'll be like hey man you know I
told my family by 20 Century I tell my
family everything
and so my family that knew about it they
still invited him back to a family
reunion barbecue knowing I was gonna be
there
you know I'm like [__] I was like but
that's just so good of a car and I saw
that he made
it I was about to say but this
[__]
that already happened to you a long time
ago like okay
yeah eat your feelings
it's pretty good I don't know what he
marinated today but [__] with me
you know what I'm saying and when you
tell that joke to a room full of
strangers duh it's the most therapeutic
thing that could that could do you know
but but the bottom line is is like when
we go through [__] like this which a lot
of people go through is like you got to
put in the work and that's what that's
that's the thing I struggle with yeah oh
no no 42. all right and this happened to
you from five to seven so look how long
this is affecting there's so many people
out there listen if this is something
that's happened to you you should
definitely talk to somebody and I I hate
that you didn't feel believed or you
know and it's still [__] with here's
the other thing that guy if I if that's
me I don't I'm not showing up to the
cookouts you know what I'm saying I'm
not coming back around yeah people
wonder why he don't come around anymore
yeah because Bill shows up yeah cause
now everybody knows and he knows that
they know and he still shows up well he
knows that my mom and dad knowing that I
know nobody else really knows homie you
know
but I I want to have a talk with him
because you went through you need to
because I'm close to this Mom and Dad's
my deal they're good people homie it's
just at this point they don't know what
happened they don't know either on me so
it's like and then you started to be
like because so after that battle
happened when they invite uh like sorry
uh after that thing happened
um or he was at the barbecue I [__]
you know I remember I was doing a show
remember you know the independent
downtown that yeah double theater I was
doing a show there that night and I'll
never forget uh I was at my mom and
dad's and they were acting like
everything was all good and I said you
guys [__] had him at the barbecue and
I [__] with that just all this
emotion came out I called my own parents
who [__] came from nothing and
provided me opportunities [__]
you know I go you [__] dude
you're inviting a backup time all this
[__] you know and my dad's he doesn't
know how to process emotionally he's old
school he's an old school G you know and
they don't have those tools you know so
I can't blame them for that they did the
best they [__] could and I'm so
grateful for that and you know but my
dad didn't know what to do he just
[__] put his arms out he's like I
don't know what I was thinking Mijo I'm
sorry
you know and I [__] hugged it out
my mom was [__] balling and then I
went to the independent theater and
[__] bam served them up homie comedy
saved my [__] saved my life too for real
but my mom and dad are some of the best
people in the world homie so I wouldn't
I wouldn't want anybody to think
anything differently of them you know
people that know my mom and dad they're
like damn man that's a good time now do
you know if your sister suffered the
same she went to Yeah by him as well no
no no no not by him I don't know we
might be getting too personal yeah
that's my sister's business that's 100
your sister's business but you know yeah
we went to some [__] man but this is
like you said it goes back to your mom
and who knows before that like I'm
trying you're trying to break this
[__] yeah disgusting cycle but to
just does this speak on my sister she is
the [__] heart and the leader of this
[__] you know she's [__] she has two
kids now she just had she has a daughter
four years old who she named after me
Frankie she her name's Frankie my
um
my daughter came down to Stella and
Frankie she hates Frank she's like I
would have hated Frankie I'm like
Frankie's a cute name it is and then now
she just had a son three months ago
Charlie so they're Frankie and Charlie
and and uh my sister's doing everything
in her power to break the [__] energy
intergenerational trauma and all that
she's reading books all this well her
daughter's almost five the age where you
suffered this [__] I mean imagine
can you even you can't even comprehend I
said my daughter is eight right now I
can't comprehend it if that would have
already happened to her and she's gone
through that like Jesus Christ and then
the the the cross is yours to bear
you're the one sitting across me right
now talking about therapy you're the one
talking about trying to break this
trauma you're the one over here saying
well my dad didn't have these coping
mechanisms and my mom it happened to her
you're the one processing every feeling
every feeling the abuse the uh reasoning
behind why these people don't have it
like it's all on you and that's a hell
of a [__] spot to be in uh to move
forward so has this scared you from
wanting to have kids
like do you think that plays a part in
it or do you want to be a dad do you
want to have I mean you come from a
place an extended family yeah yeah oh
man homie my mom and dad are on me every
day
no me don't do it right you know made a
nice woman get get married
my mom is she's gonna she's Hood as [__]
she's the most Hood one in our family
she's from the practice she her
vocabulary is this her words to me is
like I don't give a [__] if you get a
hood rat pregnant at this point you
bring me that [__] baby go get a
[__] hood rat pregnant and bring me
that baby that's what she told me yeah
so she's telling me that [__] and my my
dad usually has my back you know she's
like you gotta have a [__] baby meal
that's what we do it's familiar out here
and I'm like yeah but Mom I'm chasing
this dream again
my dad always has my back I'm gonna be
like hey let him do his thing you know
like look look you know he [__] did
it you know he's making his own Ferry on
like like you know there's even been
times in the past where I had to help
them out financially like that is a
blessing homie you know what I mean but
at that time though you know my mama's
like you gotta have a baby and I looked
at my dad I just had my back like he
always does and he looks at me and goes
just one meal
just one meal all right you know just
like [__] man so now you know I'm like
[__] well maybe I just need to go are
you seeing anyone yeah you know I I
gotta well
I I yeah I'm like separated we're
separated right now but there's there's
one in my life that I'm like if I get
married it's gonna be her you know she's
been a day one homie she was there with
me when I was sleeping on my homie's
couch [__] would loan me money every
now and then like you know I mean she's
the day one so it's like even if I don't
marry her even if I end up whatever
singers I'm taking care of her yeah I'm
taking care of her but she's two years
older than me I'm 42 so the whole baby
thing ain't gonna be with her and she
doesn't even want it and and even her
own cousins they live in Taiwan they're
like no we got good surrogates out here
we'll make sure we get a good one she's
like [__] that I don't do that here you
gotta take all the shots and all that
I'm not educating all that but she was
explaining that to me I was like all
right yeah I understand
so I don't know I'm back and forth with
it but my sister has a two kids so
either way I think will be all right but
when my dad told me that I was like [__]
man I gotta give him this baby you know
now do you find yourself as an uncle
being like protective of your niece and
nephew like and and how you will be
moving forward you already feel a sense
of like I got to protect these kids hell
yeah dog yeah like
homie the [__] that happened to me
happened in my pad that's what I wanted
to say from your own family imagine
these people out there don't know
anything about you don't give a [__]
about it and I feel bad about it
sometimes but sometimes I tell my own
primals or my family like oh who's
babysitting who hey man hey homie make
sure you [__] listen man you should
my I've had this conversation with my
daughter's mother where she thinks I
overdo it sometimes but from things I've
read you should always ask and look
let's just be honest man especially if
my daughter's having a sleepover who who
else is going to be there do you have
any older siblings any uncles or aunts
live with them any extended family do
they have guns in the house you know
[__] like that you should ask your
parenting
that's not being overprotective that's
just being smart right and at least even
if you let them still go at least you
are armed with knowledge that's what's
going on over there there's an uncle
that lives there or a grandfather or
whatever it is you should know all the
[__] lay of the Lamb when your kid's
going somewhere that you're is going to
spend the night you know and you're
right this is happening your own that's
why I was saying like is he just
babysitting you while they're gone
you're like no they're there and he's
still doing this like that's that is
mental illness so yeah but
man with that being said like my mom and
dad
they taught me a lot of good things
homie you know and and I and and uh
I never did
I didn't even smoke weeds I was like 19
you know I was just like and all my
homeboys were all thinking hey homie
you're already so funny imagine if you
got high like it'd be that more funny so
when did the drug start for you I was
like 23 already oh really yeah
it was when xcc first started popping
you feel me and uh because that [__]
like hey I'm [__] high-fiving
stranger what's up y'all let's kick it
you know
and and uh I just felt [__] good
homie I didn't feel no pain you know
what I'm saying and uh and then it moved
to
um other [__] you know anything I get my
hands like you know little pain pills
here and there get you through the day
uh but when it got weird was the the
cocaine man you know which flows like
wine in comedy clubs as you know
so it's a [__] man because I
used to be like
get it back okay hey where the homies at
where's the girls let's get a crack in
and I would still do that but I got to a
point where like oh can't wait to get
home though so that I can get really
weird especially when you got a little
bit of Fame you know we walk down the
streets people recognize this so I can't
be wrong you know so I go home
draw the curtains and it's just me in
the bag homie and that bag gives me
everything I need numbs me out homie I'm
not thinking about no pain no problems
you know you turn it you turn into a
[__] lab rat really you know when
you're there by your it's a red flag to
be doing cocaine by yourself
[Music]
but dog
you turn into a [__] lab rat homie
I'll be laying in bed
yeah it is
I'll be trying to like watch porn but
you can't even get your [__] up so I'll
be I'll be look I'll be I'll be looking
at the front of my laptop like rubbing
my little Cocoa Puff like come on come
on bro please
okay maybe that's if I do a little liner
help you know you're just a [__] lab
rat just [__] and it's like oh man
and and my I would let my I would the
last thing you want to do is look at
your cell phone when you're in that
[__] uh position
so I would start you know people start
worrying about me like where the [__] is
this [__] at you know
and then and then you start getting
[__] paranoid The Gardener showed up
like we have a whole protected like
whatever complex
uh there's six units in a billion it's
all gated and all that but the gardener
comes to you know you know make sure our
porches are cool and all that
and I'm all high as [__] been up for
like a couple days and I got my bag I'm
holding my bottle of whiskey like a baby
oh yeah I mean hand in hand let's go
hand in hand and I'm [__] thinking
it's [__] [__] food they're here
they're here to get me they found out
they know like just whatever the cops
the authorities and then I hear the
blower and then oh they're gonna blow
the cocaine away and all this [__] like
I was out of my [__] mind homie and
I'm [__] like peeking out the door
and then and then it's the [__]
Gardener man you know and I was like
[__] man but luckily
I got good friends and family and around
that time as I you know uh thank God
that you know uh you know I have
insurance and so I went and checked
myself in you did to uh rehab you know
how long before you realize you you
needed that
uh
it was basically
I got on us I would because the way I
would do it is I would once my my whole
role was once a month homie
go go ahead miss a night of sleep take
some ecstasy go to a party get wild and
then boom back to work or back to being
mental you know I just needed that one
day a month but then it got worse then
you started making money homie you're
getting these fat checks
I'm not a [__] dolphino owes anybody
nothing all my bills are paid you know
what I'm saying so you're kind of
justifying your head a little bit well
hey homie you deserve this you get on
that reward system you know we finished
the first season of the show I was it
didn't touch any drugs I'm locked in
homie when it's time to work especially
when I'm into it creatively I'm trying
to kill that [__] I'm trying to
leave my mark in this comedy [__]
because that's why I'm here on this
Earth You know just it's overwhelming to
think of how many people you you know we
meet people at shows oh my gosh you're
so funny but imagine the [__] people
that watch this podcast that are a whole
another part of the world that you're
[__] touching that shit's
overwhelming homie you know what I mean
it's Our obligation dog we gotta make
this [__] crack you know what I'm saying
and so I [__] handled that [__]
though but then when I finished I was
like all right maybe I deserve it a
little something you know Chef party a
little bit you know and then next thing
I got a [__] Tackle Box I was going
fishing except I had Xanax uh cocaine
MDMA moon rocks oh [__] [__] ketamine
homie but I was funny you went deep
homie and I still had work to do but I
was mostly doing like voiceover and it
was real covety still so I could still
be kind of a little bit weird but you
have to wear the mask and also like I'm
underneath like the mask was like that
I'm like hey how you doing I'm here
[Music]
hahaha
but I still showed up [__] [__]
you know
so uh but so so then that [__] was going
on for like a couple months and then and
then here's what happened is I had two
shows that were already sold out at
stand-up live in Phoenix right okay and
you know that's a big venue yeah yeah
well 550 over a thousand [__]
that were just already ready signed up
to go
I got on a sick one so bad I forgot what
[__] day it was and my Primo Ruben
who you got to meet is a [__] no-neck
[__] boom he's been he was
locked up all that [__] but came out
he's a feel-good story got his life
together and now you know now he's on
payroll rolling with us rolling with me
on tour helping with Logistics [__] all
that you know that's my that's my dude
and um and I forgot what day it was he
has a key to my pad and everything right
so he's rolling to come hey let's pack
up the merch just roll out you know
let's get the crew together we're going
to go to the airport and I'm just in the
living room like
like on a sick one and he walks in he's
like what the [__] [__]
and then I'm like what he's like what do
you mean what we gotta go to [__]
Phoenix we got two shows tonight and I'm
like [__]
and I said [__] it just time I got
covered and we have to cancel reschedule
he's like nah [__] that we're [__]
going he physically [__] just gets
picks me up homie takes me in the car
we're going to [__] Burbank airport
we show up to Phoenix it's like 120
degrees Yeah
you know you know the [__] at
the airport that have pictures of you
like they show they know when you're
gonna land and they want to sign and
take pictures okay thanks for watching
the show and you know [__] on me and
that and that's when it all changed for
me because my cousin you know he has my
back and and dude I don't know how like
we made it to the hotel I slept for like
an hour and a half after not sleeping
for like two days
and I don't know man the universe had my
back God whatever that day I still had a
little bit of money list I took a little
bit of money and I got through the shows
and they went good man both of them and
I got into the green room and my cousin
Reuben looks at me and say hey you got
away with one tonight [__] but
this is it you're done you know like we
gotta you got all these opportunities
you worked your ass off all these years
good throw it away for this [__] this is
the x-con coming out I'll bring up a
picture of them or maybe go pick it but
like That's my boy man he's in some of
the videos uh cholofit videos uh but
so I was like all right I need to slow
down obviously you know I forgot what
day it was and I had two shows that
night so sorry Frankie you know time to
lock it up homie and slow down and I
made that decision in my mind
I said all right time to slow down
and I couldn't do it homie I actually
got back from that trip
and I was going to check my mail on my
table and that there was a hat on the
table and I took the hat and I forgot
about a pile that was there no and I
looked at the pile and I was like nah
homie and I seriously it was like
watching myself from the outside
I just [__] got a straw went down and
it's like I couldn't stop myself and I
said all right call my agents my reps I
said look
we need to schedule this [__] in I want
to check myself in if you guys want to
drop me I don't give a [__] I'm about to
die I'm killing for you yeah you're
killing me stop [__] went homie I
[__] went to that pillow and [__]
and cleared myself up cleared my mind
how long were you there uh I did a month
and then I did a month in IOP which is
like uh when you go I did a month where
I'm just there and then I did a month
where I go nine nine a.m to like 1 pm
every day to a spot I see and then I did
that go you can leave after that yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
I need to hit that reset button homie
big time and if you've been clean since
I was clean for six months now I've been
drinking again and you know I did a
little Coke here and there but I'm so
scared now of going back to that place I
was because I was in a spot where every
time I was partying it was four times in
a row right but all right I need to
chill where I would literally it would
take me to my knees all my serotonin
everything's gone homie where I'm on my
knees where I told you in my living room
begging the universe to take this
monster away from me and luckily I gotta
go home boys man good Familia they come
through they scrape me off the ground
take me to the [__] pass start
feeding me soup and [__] come on man
you know
and but you know sometimes when a a
non-addict trying to understand an
addict is very difficult sometimes
because they're like they don't get it
they're like what the [__] man you're
making all this money and you're [__]
what are you doing
it's because you know it's it it's the
only time that I feel free is when I'm
on you know and I'm grateful that yeah
I'm able to pay my bills now and I'm
making this money and all that but that
[__] don't mean happiness on me that
[__] don't mean success success is a a
difficult [__] dog you get more
[__] pulling at you you get more people
expecting things from you get people
that feel like they owe you something
you know and you owe them something I
mean yeah yeah they feel like like I owe
them something just because I became
successful I don't know what you [__] oh
you should I made this happen from
nothing you know what I'm saying and and
and what they also don't know is that
you're not
at least what I'm learning about your
story is when somebody walks in and sees
you in this state it's not all Frankie's
got money and he's a junkie now it's
what they don't know is the demon demons
you've been battling since five years
old and trying to get this [__] thing
out of you that's that's I really feel
like if you can I don't know for you
Frankie I mean I feel like if you can
take that [__] cousin out and at
least have that conversation you want
and maybe if you get the I'm sorry then
maybe it'll help yeah you know maybe
it'll help it seems like it's something
you want yeah it may be more need maybe
more need for you at this point yeah
you're a [__] you're in your 40s now
this guy's at least 10 years older right
so he's in his 50s yeah
it's even more important than that he
does even more important than that
though I think it's just me working it
out and uh you know in the therapy rooms
you know and I got some their
[__] this is their specialty
you know is is addiction
traumas all that but the thing is I
struggle in those rooms man because I
still
like I'm you know I've been suppressing
that [__] for 27 years doc so it's it's
deep in there so it's just taking it you
know and I can see a frustrating the
therapist too it's taking it a long time
because I'll deflect it even when I
start crying about oh [__] I'm sorry I'm
sorry okay anyways and she's like no let
that [__] go [__] stop let the
tears go yes process this [__] feel it
you know she wants me to like describe
the the memories of it and walk up to
her through it I can't I can't [__]
do it homie you know but I want to get
there now the thing is that I'm working
on it it's just hard work I think you
did a hell of a good job here today
talking about that on a show like this
and putting that out there I mean this
is the most I put it out there so hey
love y'all [__] y'all [__] have
been through this [__] then I hope this
is helpful to somebody please don't and
I hope none of you are like oh dang that
fool's all [__] weirdo well actually
I'm a weirdo so [__] I accept it you
know but anybody would think that that
that happened to a five-year-old kid I
mean Jesus Christ I go back to thinking
about my daughter was five when the
pandemic hit and you know she's just
learned how to read Santa's real to her
you know what I mean yeah
you could tell a kid at that age
anything we do we talk about Santa
Easter Bunnies tooth fairies Jesus all
that [__] we tell them all these
things and they believe it all because
they trust you yeah you did nothing
wrong this guy I mean violated every
aspect of of trust with you in every
sense right and then continued to do it
yeah and then you [__] stood up for
yourself and gets brushed under a rug
literally dude showing up in and out of
your life of course you're gonna have
[__] feelings about that and then the
older you get also I can imagine too
when once you started feeling like I'm
getting stronger and stuff yeah you know
then you start feeling different things
like I want to [__] this [__] up
I went through those stages yeah angry
I would never talk to my parents how I
say when I before I did that show at the
independent theater [__] yeah
my my pops went to my cousin's work
during the day and and and yeah and yeah
and you know so what do you say he just
said he went to his job yeah and he's
like yeah you know pull him out he's
like hey homie
uh Frankie's pissed I I know you
remember what happened and he said my
cousin broke down started crying and
then he said man it's always been the
one thing I regretted in my life too and
I'm sorry you know he's like stay you
know you're not invited to the house
anymore and all that and then just let
it be it did make me feel better that at
least he felt apologetic and you know
but I want to have that talk to him face
to face yeah so I will say that you know
because that that happened so well
that's better than him denying it and
saying it's [__] yeah anything like
that for you he might be like what I
never did that right right no no he it
got he was crying so I was like all
right you know and he's a [__] big
old looking [__] too so here's
the other thing too man unfortunately
this might be the beginning of you
helping other people and your family
come forward about maybe it happened to
them as well yeah you know what I mean
like you might be saving other people by
helping yourself in the end yeah well
yeah even when I do that joke I told you
about the name
every time I do that joke man never not
one time have I not gotten at least one
two to five messages from audience
members being like thank you for that
joke here's what happened to me right
you know and so
I don't know man you know I'm not here
to like save the world and I don't
believe like that whatever but just by
saying yourself you're saving a lot of
[__] people yeah it's just
it's something I'm always gonna struggle
with because you know my family parties
on me like you know that's what we do
[__] barbecues tequila [__] you
know fools are crying fools are fighting
it's like that's that's a that's that's
that's a that's a typical family
Barbecue in our family you know what I'm
saying
you know so
it's something I always struggle with
but as long as I put in that work you
know I go to meetings and [__] do you
you know sometimes what you know I was
drinking for uh I was six months totally
sober and then I started drinking and I
was good for like four and a half months
and then [__] one night got me dog
started hitting that [__] pop oh [__]
there it is oh dang it does feel good
and aren't you scared today now too with
fentanyl and everything that one bad
bump's gonna [__] work yeah you're
saying you're gone I used to get it from
whoever but I got the one plug that I
know is that good good but but
or yeah and so they gotta put the alert
out you know and they they just let they
text those fools and those fools are you
know they they they're they're about it
too
and and there was one of my pretty ones
who was serving me and he was and I was
at it was like once a week and he goes
hey homie you good are they oh nice for
another comedian homie and it's not for
my me homie I'm done you know I got [__]
to do you know and then I'll go right to
the [__] pattern
you know it's just like so for the
schools I got my back man another you
know and I'm very grateful for that
because I might not be alive if it
wasn't for them you know but let me tell
you something you had your back yeah you
did thank God you did yeah because you
wouldn't be alive no you would have
drunk or [__] drugged yourself to
death or anything and thank God you're
not repeating this [__] abusive
vicious cycle and that you're in the
middle of it trying to figure out how to
stop it and man I feel for you dude good
for you though thank you yeah yeah I'm
I'm going to meetings I'm doing the
thing the thing is is that you have to
do the work you know or else it's gonna
get you like I can't do it alone on me
every day my own mind or myself is
trying to destroy myself have you ever
tried EMG ER therapy I'm gonna do that
next good yeah
yeah little buzzers in your hand it
[__] works yeah it works I had to go
for it
um and the the good thing is it's not
talk therapy there's an end to it you'll
know when you're done with it you'll be
like that's it that's it damn
all right look dude thank you for this
episode I know we got to get you out of
here no no no we're good it's okay good
homie but we're right there at the end I
want to tell you
um first of all thank you I know that
she's not easy to talk about there's a
lot of people are going to reach out to
you about this and thank you for this
it's honestly homie thank you for even
like willing to be going there with me
and to to go through it I mean I'm
probably gonna cry after this but damn
I'm trying not to cry on camera but
as [__] up as a [__] that that is and
um all the struggles that my family went
through they took care of me man and the
best that they could
and with that being said all the pain
that I have in me
you know without without the darkness
Ain't No Light homie and so
like there's a big part of me that's
grateful that I have this pain in me
because when I'm able to go make people
laugh and smile
like that [__] is like an explosion to
me that I might not have ever
experienced if I didn't go through this
pain
you know what I'm saying so it's like
I'm grateful for all my fans all the
people that [__] with me all the people
that watch my sketch videos and TV shows
all that [__] I never you know and it's
never what you expect it's gonna be like
you think one day like damn homie
imagine if I was on a TV show like
that'd be crazy then you get there and
it's just more stress and work man but
you are grateful you are like damn not a
thing so the thing is the thing I focus
on is that I got an opportunity to make
people feel good and in fact my goal is
to touch as many people as I can on this
Earth I know I'm not for everybody but
the for the for the ones that rock with
me they really rock with me homie yeah
and so I want to do I want to do as much
dope work and dope feel good [__] as
possible before I leave this earth and
so yeah and that all you know and all
that work and grindness and and uh just
happiness that it came from that
darkness and that pain and so I'm just
very grateful for that I'm grateful for
people like you that see that and have
my back and are willing to have these
conversations and uh so thank you man
thank you Ryan I appreciate it listen
thank yourself because all that is great
everybody is you've mentioned is
wonderful but you had your [__] back
you had your [__] back a lot of
people don't ever figure that out yeah
yeah you know a lot of people don't even
know they can stick up for themselves or
how to do it and you're going through
the pain in the process so good for you
dude
um before we wrap up I told you I'm
gonna ask you after whatever we talk
about advice you would give to your 16
year old self oh yeah yeah
now considering what we've just talked
about like 16 years old I would say
therapy is not just for white people
[__]
yeah all right
I will say yeah yeah
um you know I would say that therapy's
not white people and and
um you know uh it's not your fault and I
I don't know man I would just say that
uh just uh
I don't know man get that [__] out
[__] is what I would tell my 16
year old self you know
quit holding it in yeah
but with that being said I've had a good
life I'm very grateful man a lot I'm
glad you're still here you could have
been in a statistic a long time ago yeah
yeah
um Frankie thank you so much one more
time again please plug promote
everything all of it oh yeah just go to
uh Frankie quinones.com I'll be at uh
let's see uh I'll be out standard Black
Phoenix on uh June 30th I'll be at
Houston Improv uh the last weekend of
July I'll be at the comedy Den in uh
Chicago in August uh but the main thing
is please tune in to the second season
of this four on Hulu all 10 episodes
drop on July 28th uh so that should be
cracking and then I'll be on the
upcoming season of what we do in the
shadows uh then you can go to my YouTube
watch that cholo feed homies you can go
to trouble creeper on his Instagram you
know homie and uh yeah take care of
yourselves do the damn thing feel good
be nice to somebody today you feel me
that [__] helps
yeah yeah that's great advice be nice to
somebody today yeah yeah
um as always Ryan sickler.com Ryan
sickler on all your social media share
the YouTube special come see me on tour
check out the patreon we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
foreign